determining the right price for your
retail products is a difficult task
price item's too high and you might lose
business price them too low and you
lower your profit margin
so how do you incorporate different data
sources to analyze historical pricing
trends and make predictions on future
demand
today we'll show you how using google's
data cloud
[Music]
there are lots of different data sources
that can help you understand how to
optimally price items
you might have information on
transactions
details on products like categories and
list prices
and data on the customers themselves
however the data required to drive
pricing insight is often disparate
potentially coming from different
systems with their own formats
one way to make working with these
sources more effective is to combine key
attributes into a single cleaned and
standardized schema
which we'll refer to as the common data
model or cdm
in this tutorial we'll use data prep by
trifecta to standardize data coming from
different sources and unify the
necessary fields in the cdm table which
will live in bigquery
our fully managed scalable data
warehouse
once data is formatted for analysis
we'll show how analysts can explore
historical trends to understand the
impact of prior pricing changes
additionally we'll use bigquery's
machine learning capabilities to create
predictive models that estimate future
sales
finally we'll use the output of these
models within a looker dashboard to
create what-if scenarios where business
users can analyze what sales might look
like with certain price changes
so let's jump in
inside of data prep you create flows
which represent a data pipeline
within this flow we have connected each
of our data sets
in this case we're using google sheets
and a table containing our customer
descriptions in bigquery
but you can connect a variety of
different data sources including flat
files transactional databases and sas
tools like salesforce
you might notice that we have one
transaction file for each month
representing the orders that were placed
in that period
the first thing you'll want to do is
combine those files
in dataprep you use recipes to transform
and join data together
opening this recipe
you can see that there are actually two
things happening
first we're unioning or combining the
transactions data into one single set
but then we're standardizing customer
descriptions
this is because the names of customers
are sometimes misspelled or represented
differently across transactions
but with data prep you can use a fuzzy
matching algorithm to standardize
customer names with similar strings
where values with characters in common
are clustered together or pronunciation
where values that sound alike are
clustered together
this way we make sure customers are
represented consistently
outside of the transactions recipe we
have other recipes to calculate accurate
pricing using functions that pivot
aggregate and join to customer data
and a recipe that automatically
reformats the prepared data structure to
match the existing cdm table schema
using dataprep's rapid target
functionality
finally the cdm is pushed into bigquery
and not only can we manually run this
flow
but we can also set it to run on a
scheduled basis
so the cdm table is always fresh
with our prepared data in bigquery we're
ready to take a look at what's happened
historically when we've changed the
price of an item
here we're using standard sql to create
a temporary table with one row for each
price change
and it contains relevant information
like the total number of orders at the
current price point
compared to orders at the previous price
point
with this temp table in place we can do
things like look at the average price
change
or see how sales have changed relative
to the price difference
now that we have historical analysis
squared away let's incorporate machine
learning to predict what will happen in
the future
with bigquery ml we can build an arima
model one of the most widely used
approaches for statistical forecasting
with time series
and this will use historical sales for
each product to predict the future
demand all in just a few lines of sql
how cool is that
so using bigquery we're able to draw
insights from huge amounts of data in no
time
but to empower business decision makers
we want to create a report accessible by
the broader team
this is where looker comes into play
with looker we create a data model using
looker semantic layer look ml
that stores the definitions of our
metrics using sql
looker uses this model to compile and
send sql queries back to bigquery on
behalf of non-technical users
this means we take full advantage of the
power and intelligence that bigquery
offers
all while giving business users the
ability to explore governed data without
needing an analyst to write sql for them
with our lookml model in place we can
build out a dashboard to influence
pricing decisions
here we've built a report that surfaces
historical trends
building off of that temp table we
created earlier
and because looker compiles sql on the
fly we can drill all the way to sku
level detail from any tile
scrolling down on the report we've also
created a what if tool
where decision makers can see what might
happen if they change the price of
products
for example
if you wanted to see what would happen
if the order volume went down to 75 of
the protected value
and pricing across all products was
raised by 25
and the best part this is all just the
beginning there are lots more ways that
google cloud can help you optimize your
retail pricing like leveraging
geospatial analytics features to see how
the proximity of competitors impact
sales
or incorporating publicly available data
like weather and search trends into your
analysis
so if you're interested in learning more
about google's data cloud then make sure
to check out the links below
including a step-by-step tutorial of
what we showed today
you